my name is Deepak Chopra born in New
Delhi India I think where you're born
brings a history with it a cultural
history a mythical history and ancestral
history religious context and certainly
in fluences your perceptions of the
world and how you interpret everyday
reality it shaped my reality where i was
born in two ways one i was burdened by
the culture i was born in and secondly
gave me a context with which to actually
see with wise eyes as well so culture is
both a burden and as well as an
opportunity for look at the world
through the eyes of wisdom as the young
person I was influenced by my parents
mostly by my mother who was a great
storyteller I was also influenced by the
political environment of a country that
had just gained freedom from British
colonialism and the seminal figures in
that environment Mahatma Gandhi who had
been assassinated shortly after I was
born but nevertheless dominated the
collective psyche of the country and of
course there were other statesman like
mr. Nehru were very much part of the
cultural milieu as well as looked upon
by society as leaders and mentors and
people that inspired us to have a vision
for idealism
I heard about what PETA very early in my
childhood from the age of five onwards
so it was one of the earliest things I
started to read when I started to read
and it was very much part of my
consciousness in the beginning I saw the
bug would beat Geeta as a text that was
very classical much like the Iliad and
the Odyssey mythical saga that showed
the eternal conflict between good and
evil but much later as I grew up I
realized that it was much more than that
at what it was an examination of
consciousness and the desire of human
beings of the quest that we have as
human beings to understand ourselves
that it was the map you might say for
exploring the territory and that leads
us to find out things about herself who
are we where do we come from was the
meaning and purpose of our existence do
we have a soul what happens to us after
we die does God exist does God in fact
care about us how can we get in touch
with that source that we call
consciousness is the consciousness
behind our thoughts also the
consciousness responsible for all the
intelligent activity of the universe the
Bhagwad Gita is actually a very good
text for yoga the yoga of love the yoga
of action or karma the yoga of
understanding or intellect and the yoga
of reflection and meditation so I think
it's a very important map for
understanding the nature of
consciousness
the word yoga is the same as the English
word yoke so in the New Testament when
Jesus Christ as the my yoke is easy and
my burden is light my interpretation is
that he's referring to yoga it means
Union union of the body mind and the
spirit is one continuum of consciousness
I think the Bhagwad Gita is about both
the forces of light and the forces of
darkness that exists within our own self
within our own soul that our deepest
nature is one of ambiguity we have
evolutionary forces their forces of
creativity and love and compassion and
understanding but we also have darkness
inside us the diabolical forces of
separation fear and delusion and in most
of our lives there's a battle going on
within ourselves between the sacred and
the profane between the evolutionary
impulses and the destructive tendencies
and that we have between creativity on
the one hand and addictive behavior on
the other hand between the divine and
the diabolical between the light and the
shadow between the sacred and the
profane so the mugwort Gita is an
understanding of this battle that we
have in our consciousness that
ultimately is played out in the
battlefield that you recall our physical
bodies in the physical universe so by
understanding the dynamics of these
forces within our own consciousness and
by beginning to harmonize our impulses
with the evolutionary impulse within us
we heal ourselves and in doing so we
heal not only our physical bodies but
our world because the world that we find
ourselves in is
in both of our personal consciousness
and our collective consciousness so I
think it's very relevant to modern times
when you see things like global warming
and climate chaos and changing weather
patterns and natural disasters like
hurricane katrina and extreme poverty
and economic disparities and social
injustice and war and terrorism these
are the projection of a collective
consciousness that's in disarray of a
collective consciousness where there is
a rift in the collective soul a
collective consciousness that is
evolving but is going through a lot